hello everybody and welcome to the
precision medicine virtual event my name
is Florence Comte and I will be speaking
on precision medicine and health in
action practicing an end of one approach
in the clinic please feel free to submit
questions during my presentation I will
be happy to follow up with you via email
my learning objectives for this
presentation is first to understand the
core principles and potential
applications of precision medicine and
end of one healthcare and secondly to
review a practical model for leveraging
and of one data to detect and predict
disease NIH of course put precision
medicine on the map this started in 2015
when President Obama announced the fact
that precision medicine meant that each
person would have the right drug at the
right time for the right person and very
recently about a year ago on May 6th
which happened to be my mom's birthday
NIH announced that national enrollment
for all of us research program was set
to advanced precision medicine I
enrolled and I encourage all of you
enroll because diversity is going to be
key the definition that NIH uses which
is slightly different than mine is that
precision medicine is an emerging
approach for disease treatment and
prevention that takes into account
variability and genes environment and
lifestyle for each person and this is
why precision medicine matters each of
us is very different you don't have to
be as distinctly unique as Shaq and
Danica but we do know that even the top
ten drugs which were widely studied and
published in peer review evidence based
medicine models don't work well for
everybody and here you can see in one of
my favorite papers published in Nature
personalized medicine time for one
person trials in April of 2015 by
Nicholas
work that some of the top 10 medications
are only useful in one of many folks
that they're used in so there's an issue
with the fact that not all of us
appropriately can use medications that
have been widely tested as an identical
twin I knew that a long time ago and
when genomics started emerging when the
billion-dollar genome was published in
the 1990s I was fascinated because it's
an identical twin genomics always was of
interest to me but I knew then that I
was not quite identical to my twin
sister and I was interested in all the
other omics whether it was metabolomics
and looking at metabolism or hormones or
looking at the microbiome or looking at
the mic or any aspect of the omics it
would all be pertinent and there I was
at Yale creating women's health and
men's health and interested in
collecting any and all of the data I can
on each unique person anticipating
genomics but wondering if as a clinical
investigator I could actually determine
what was going on beneath the surface in
anticipation of genomics so in
collecting information whether it was
about the metabolism or hormones or
looking at personal and family history
and lifestyle issues putting together
all these domains and the tsunami of
information allowed me to detect
variations in what was expressed by the
gene and in how a person lived would
tell me what was going on under the
surface and in doing so we were able to
detect predict and actually look at
reversing the health trajectory or the
disease trajectory so that it wouldn't
go downhill with aging this would allow
an individual to own their own health
trajectory so why is that critical well
it's critical because our health
actually Peaks before 30 and
we hit out there DS we begin to notice
changes in our health and that happens
physiologically hormones change
metabolism changes heart disease begins
to permeate and emerge in males before
the age of 40 we begin to change in
terms of the way bone turns over
fertility and a number of markers of
health biomarkers of health are notable
below the surface is that a clinical as
a clinical investigator that was
apparent to me so I began to collect
that data in the hopes that we could
identify those biomarkers and reverse
those changes before decline set in and
the promise of sustaining health for a
lifespan would be available then to
individuals so to me this led to another
definition of precision medicine that
predated what NIH is now trying to do
and allowed me to collect this data so
precision medicine in health is a data
based approach to optimal health and
longevity that integrates and interprets
an individual's end of one health
portfolio over time to detect predict
and reverse disorders of aging with
personalized interventions I want to
explain what that means from an N of one
perspective what essentially we're
saying is that when we study we're
studying a single patient as the entire
clinical trial now that's the way I
thought more than two decades ago that
by collecting individualized data and
collecting it in such a way that while
the clinic looked like a clinic by
perception we were actually using it and
the surface as a clinic as a center but
underneath we were collecting data in a
very appropriate way but in a singular
way where every patient had biomarkers
collected at baseline as if it was a
clinical investigative trial not unlike
what
historic was advocating in his paper in
nature that it's time for one-person
trials that precision medicine requires
a different type of clinical trial that
focuses on the individual but doesn't
average responses to therapy in anyway
interpreting data and by doing so what
we collected was all this individual
data that you see laid out here I
couldn't embed a video here but you can
go to the website and check this out and
comment tmz.com
you can see that what we're interested
in all these hexagons is all the bits
and bytes that make up a person's life
their personal and family history which
I used to think of as a poor man's
genetic test and now recognize after
years of collecting on thousands and
thousands individuals longitudinally
that it's a very rich form of
information because it's in the
emergence of genetic data so family
history personal history lifestyle
weather sleep nutrition the way we live
and exercise or don't whether it's
10,000 steps or several steps today
metabolic data hormones and functional
tests we look at vo2 and exercise
testing and metabolic equivalence which
is a great predictor of morbidity and
mortality we also collect any and all
digital data wearables and we look at
apps and whether it's several snips or
the whole genome we also collect genomic
data and by doing so we connect and and
all these dots we integrate it and we
interpret it and we find out where these
spots the weak spots are or the
liabilities as you see in the red dots
and then we intervene and hopefully
cause them to turn green so there's
health that's created and we think of
that as an end of one precision health
engine another way of looking at this
process is remotely we can collect
records and surveys we don't need to see
an individual to do that because we're
looking below the surface and then we
can do a blood draw that looks at all
these biomarkers and interpret it
through a telemedical consultation
where we actually connect the dots for
that individual to get them comfortable
with what we're seeing beneath the
surface emerging and while we see them
and they they visit us we also collect
bone density data and body composition
we do all sorts of testing at the Center
in New York and then we tailor
interventions to achieve optimal health
and we continue to do that over time
while assessing outcomes with various
markers these are a number of our
clients and we can see any and every one
and you can see they all look unique we
can assess what's going on beneath the
surface in any way because what's on the
surface does not really tell us what's
happening beneath the surface you can
look amazing such as this gentleman in
the middle but yet what's going on
underneath may not look as good so I got
call rather recently from a 47-year
young now who was actually in very good
shape mmm he had an 8 pack in fact and
that's what he reported but he travelled
frequently between time zones as he was
an actor with a very comfortable
lifestyle worked out five to seven times
a week and was eating a pretty low-carb
diet
no alcohol smoked occasionally he did
crave carbs at night had occasional
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches and
could get through a pint of ice cream
didn't like the fact that he had these
cravings and couldn't stop them no acute
symptoms at all he did sleep well six to
eight hours no he had a family history
of cardiovascular disease and diabetes
and he felt that this could be the
underlying reason for why it was
disturbing him this carb craving because
he saw that his father was now an
insulin dependent diabetic and also had
some heart disease it was hard for his
father to ambulate without pain and he
was worried that he was following in his
father's tracks and other family members
also had heart disease and diabetes and
he really wasn't feeling as good as he
did in his 20s even though he looked
great on the outside
anyone hearing this might have felt that
wow this guy seemed great and there was
really nothing to worry about so from a
conventional medicine point of view
anybody who looked at this would have
thought that I lost my mind to think
that there was any problem going on with
this gentleman and that I would should
have just told him just take it easy and
you're a little anxious and there's
nothing to worry about and come back
when you're really sick because you're
doing great but the truth of the matter
is there's no way to tell if he's doing
well and the fact is he was giving off
some signals based on the thousands of
people that I've seen over the years
that told me that underneath his carb
cravings his family history and a nun
number of other signals meant that there
was something going on under the surface
and the data would speak to it so we
went on to look at the data and the way
we look at data tells us that he had
issues in his car metabolism because
somebody like this 47 year young
gentleman who was doing mostly
everything right should not have an
elevated fasting sugar as shown here his
fasting sugar should be between 70 and
80 and instead it was 91 and as
hemoglobin a1c optimally should be
closer to 5 or less and it was 5.4 and
his insulin should be undetectable when
you fast for several hours overnight and
it was not and there were a number of up
variables that were not what they should
be his cholesterol was too high and
those sent signals to me that said we
start we should start looking at what's
going on here because he's not in good
health and this is a pattern that's
bound to go downhill with aging so we
did just that we took a look at a deeper
dive into his lipids and as you can see
here without even looking at the numbers
that he had a lot of red red is bad so
this is a test a particular test that
look at lipid particles and he had high
numbers of the bad small particles the
LDL not only that but he had genetic
variables that
said that they were almost unchangeable
unless he had some radical interventions
and he had some genomic snips as well
but here when I'm pointing out is we
didn't need to wait for the genome to be
available to say that this was a
gentleman who was headed as many of us
are with aging down a path that would
take away optimal health and as he aged
he too would be heading towards diabetes
and heart disease and he had snips that
suggested if we didn't turn around his
supplements and make sure that he was
getting for example sufficient vitamins
such as the vitamins because he had a
variant that would not allow him to take
in certain B vitamins and methylate them
he was also at higher risk for heart
disease and for all those reasons we
chose to intervene to see if we could
turn around his health issues here are
some of his initial findings that are
already described he had an abnormal
carbohydrate panel which speaks to sugar
and hemoglobin a1c and insulin abnormal
lipids or cholesterol he also had a low
magnesium and a vitamin D he had an
elevated homocysteine which spoke to
inadequate vitamins in particular B
vitamins he had a high sex toy binding
globulin he had something by pattern
alone as an endocrinologist that we
would describe as hypokinetic tropic
hypogonadism which meant he had fairly
low testosterone and we made several
recommendations that would lead to
deeper testing looking at an oral
glucose tolerance tests with repeat
baseline testing advanced lipid testing
and genetic testing we also chose to
recommend deeper cardiovascular
assessment doing something called a
coronary risk ratio which we had
obtained and we wanted to do a
computerized tomography calcium score
with the pulmonary CT and a CT or CT
angiogram that would look to see if he
already had stenosis due to the
underlying risks that he was facing as
well as the family history we suggested
that he increased his consumption of
protein with carbs and we wanted to help
him stop smoking altogether because that
was escalating his risk of these
underlying conditions and he was fully
on board with the program this is what
he looked like when he came in and I
think you can appreciate how good he
looks on the surface again this would be
a person who everybody would agree look
fantastic
why will researching for any data that
would that would tell us otherwise
but in pointing out the precision with
which we want to look at data you could
see that the data in conjunction with
his story gave us this valuable insight
and where as he checked out with respect
to his is lean muscle mass and his
present body fat of nine point seven he
still had a ways to go with health and
here's where the end of one approach
makes a difference because he would have
qualified as somebody that you might not
want to spend too much time and you
might think it's a waste of time and
money to do anything more than just a
superficial annual exam but this
gentleman was headed towards poor health
we also did a vo2 max test which would
give us insight into something called
metabolic equivalence which is a very
strong predictor of morbidity and
mortality and he looked very good that
way and with some intervention even
early on we actually improved his
metabolic equivalents significantly
within a few months but here's his CT
angiogram and a CT calcium score and he
was already in the seventy-fifth to 90th
percentile due to the amount of calcium
in his coronary arteries and he had some
significant stenosis meaning there was a
readi plaque buildup this was not good
news for a 47 year old and this is the
not in this particular gentleman because
he already wanted to intervene but this
is the reason you might see a marathoner
who thinks he's doing everything right
died of a heart attack because there is
changes there are changes that go on
beneath the surface that lead to disease
and when you don't collect data that's
precise and marry it to the story the
way we look at end of one data in each
individual person and when you look to
just averaging the mean and being
somebody who looks this good must be
healthy you are going to miss disease
and as we age all of us are going to
have disorders of Aging
so the end of one programming for those
of us who are familiar and many of you
will be familiar with an end of one it's
developing a data informed intervention
whether it's using sleep or modalities
that are quite conservative but can
change radically the the course of your
health trajectories for those of our
patients or as we like to think of them
clients because we don't want them ill
nutrition exercise or doing more
advanced testing to get holistic deeper
or wearables which is something that we
also spoke to with this gentleman
supplements or medications we want to
intervene to make sure that we have
progress and in this particular
gentleman we are interested in doing
some intervention and he was able to
choose a few things that made a
difference for example we suggested that
we discontinue intermittent vesting and
we try to ketogenic diet we reduced to
strength training and we increased more
intermittent aerobic and steady cardio
to minimize further increases in muscle
we also suggested that he start a
hormonal intervention to utilize his
natural physiology something called
human chorionic and in tropen we've
started him on D vitamin we also started
on some omegas and cocoa flavanols to
increase memory which was also an issue
we gave him root of astragalus because
that would help lengthen telomeres his
excellent data and we gave him a
prescription medication to help abate
his desire to smoke so there were a
number of interventions that helped move
him in the right direction fairly
rapidly and he was on board with almost
all of it we also because he was
interested in owning some of his own
information he was fascinated by the
notion of a wearable so we placed a CGM
on him which was able to look at the
sugar content in his body of foods that
he ate and we could assess this using
different devices the particular device
we used is placed on the tricep and it
looks at patterns and when you eat and
each individual has quite a different
pattern and it's fascinating to people
to get this information at the point of
eating instead of waiting for data to
come back and just getting one moment in
time through a fast and so he was able
to do just this and change the patterns
for himself I want to share another
study with you that actually looked at
metabolic typing this was reported in
cell and showed that you can take many
individuals I think this study was done
in about a thousand individuals and if I
point to the upper right hand side as
you're facing the slide you'll see that
this particular participant number four
forty five when eating a banana there
was a rise in sugar but when eating up
he is shown by the blue line the banana
is in the yellow line quite
appropriately the banana cause the sugar
to go up higher than the cookie but if
you compare that individual to the other
participant number six for for the
reverse happened the cookie cause the
sugar to go up whereas the banana did
not so you can see the when you look at
averages of people you squash
differences you can't really discern
what a particular individual
is going to do I've been wearing one of
these monitors despite not being a
diabetic for about three years now and
it's completely changed as an
endocrinologist that I am my
understanding of my own function and I
can't urge all of us enough to
understand that end of one approach to
figuring out how our bodies function is
going to be the medicine of the future
here you could see that leveraging and
of one data and patterns over time is
vital and there's a number of ways we
look at it and we do a deep dive into
each of the individuals that come to the
center ultimately although much of what
we do is telephonic and at a distance
and the changes that happen over time
can really make a difference his PSA
here just to pick out a couple of
numbers stayed steady despite what we
were doing which is excellent we want
that to change number of his variables
did change over time and we adjust
accordingly I would like to talk for a
moment about how we think of the nf1
approach and this to me goes way back a
couple of decades and it rests in the
fact that anyone essentially starts with
observing as we have thousands of
individuals and collecting a data
designed as a clinical investigative
trial and as you do that you're looking
at data that forms patterns enough folks
fall into certain patterned responses
and as you collect that data you're able
to observe it look at it and over time
formulate the population theory in
contrast to collecting lots and lots of
data the way the NIH is approaching it
looking at a million lives and then
theorizing how to bring that down to the
individual in fact in that paper that I
started out with in nature by Nicolas
store in April of 2015 he describes what
I've been doing here at the Center for
two decades in New York for a slightly
over a decade about 13 years now and
what Nicholas stork actually wrote out
is that this n of one approach
essentially starts out small and focused
and then works its way towards insights
that would immediately benefit a much
larger group and that's what we have
found because I want to stress it of
course you can't study globally what we
need to determine to help everybody in
the way we're doing it the center one at
a time
but we have plans to scale this kind of
approach into an app that will allow us
to offer this kind of approach broadly
and here you can see what we intend to
do is take the patterns that we have now
been studying and look at the
individuals where the green or pink or
blue collect all the essential data that
we want to collect offer it up through
the app and offer it globally so that by
seeing and quantifying this data and
marrying it to the particular story of
an individual we'd be able to evoke
change that would have an individual
change their path so that they can own
their own health destiny I hope this
makes sense it's been fun to talk about
what we've been doing here in New York
thank you if you feel interested in
contacting us please feel free both to
send an email here and I'm happy to
answer through this presentation if
you'd like to reach us beyond this you
can feel free to write to us through the
website at info at comte mtv.com thank
you very much